this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building a beautiful website and growing
your online presence more on them a bit
later he inherited a small investigative
Bureau and turned it into the largest
most pervasive and most efficient
federal law enforcement agency like an
unshakable Colossus he cast his shadow
over the darkest and most momentous
times of American History the world wars
the red scares the Cold War the civil
rights movement and the Mysterious
assassinations of the 1960s his name was
of course jadega Hoover the legendary
and controversial director of the FBI
foreign
[Music]
was born on the 1st of January 1895 from
birth everything pointed to a manifest
destiny within civil service to start
with he was born in Washington DC and
came from a family who had served the
federal government for Generations his
father Dickerson Naylor Hoover worked
for the U.S Coast survey office in fact
but the real moral guide of the family
was his mother Annie J Edgar would
remain extremely close to her living in
the same house of seaward Square until
her death in 1938. Jay proved from the
start that he had an Iron Will and a
competitive streak marred by a
stuttering problem in his high school
years he overcame it by joining the
debate team and developing an extremely
quick speech pattern after graduation
Jay Edgar enrolled at George Washington
University Law School in October of
1913. he attended night classes as
during the day was busy working at the
Library of Congress Jay Edgar was posted
within the orders Department in charge
of acquiring books and manuscripts for
the library's collection but what he
really excelled at was sorting filing
and cataloging material organizing
across referencing complex information
in other words nobody could imagine it
at the time but young Hoover was
learning the foundations of what would
become one of the FBI's most efficient
weapons its filing system after a
successful period with the library J
Edgar finished Law School in 1917. that
very April the U.S joined World War one
against the central Empires and was of
the right age to join the other
Doughboys headed to the front of France
but Hoover would not be facing the
troops of the Kaiser as he had already
gotten a draft exempt position with the
Department of Justice on the 26th of
July 1917. critics speculate this was a
calculated move to avoid the trenches
but it is also likely that young Hoover
had to take the job to provide for his
family his dad Dickerson who suffered
from a mental illness had been forced
out at the job without a pension for a
year Huber may have found himself at the
Department of Justice out of necessity
or convenience but he absolutely
excelled at the job in November of 1918
he was named assistant to the attorney
general A Mitchell Palmer and by 1919 he
was leading the Department's General
Intelligence Division the those were the
years of the first Red Scare the period
in which U.S institutions feared that
anarchists and Communists may attempt to
overthrow the government Palmer's enmity
against subversive movements was
reciprocated in June of 1919 an
anarchist group bombed his home Palmer
was unscathed but he was seething the
Attorney General launched a campaign
against all radicals and he appointed
his Protege Hoover to lead the newly
formed radical division at the justice
department in January and February of
1920 barely 25 years of age Hoover
organized a series of raids against
suspected or confirmed left-wing
activists only on one occasion he
personally LED in the field such actions
the Roundup of an Italian Anarchist
group in Paterson New Jersey Hoover
clearly impressed his superiors by
displaying remarkable organizational
skills and determination at a very young
age but the so-called Parma raids became
known because of the blatant disregard
for the basic rights of those involved
Hoover acted without any search or
arrest warrants 556 suspects were
deported with scarce evidence of
subversive activity the young head of
the radical division also targeted and
spied on the lawyers defending these
suspects one of these whom he defined as
most dangerous man in the United States
was Felix Frankfurter who later became a
Supreme Court Justice the Draconian
methods applied in the palmarades gave
ammunition to the political Rivals of
the Attorney General they forced Palmer
to resign but Hoover's reputation
remained unscathed he continued climbing
through the ranks of the Department of
Justice the Intelligence Division was
absorbed by the Department's Bureau of
Investigation or Boi in 1921 and J Edgar
was appointed assistant director the Boi
was in terrible shape it was a small
investigative offer staffed by political
appointees with no policing experience
relying on an outdated and disorganized
filing system that's where Hoover's
reforms kicked off capitalizing on his
experience as a librarian the young
assistant director revolutionized the
indexing system allowing his agents to
quickly locate and correlate Vital
Information his efforts were noticed at
government level on May 10 1924 attorney
general Harlan Fisk Stone promoted
Hoover to the role of director of the
Boi now completely in charge the
ambitious civil servant continued his
overhaul of the bureau
[Music]
The Next Step was to reform Recruitment
and training principles the director no
longer tolerated political nepotism and
set out to design the blueprint for the
G-Man the heroic government men who
upheld federal law Hoover's ideal
candidate are to be male white
preferably of wasp background
college-educated better if in law and
accounting clean shaven smartly dressed
polite cool under every circumstance and
that's why the director would dismiss
applicants with sweaty Palms most of all
future agents had to be morally
irreprehensible they had to abstain from
drink tobacco gambling and romantic and
sexual Liaisons would be agents went
through a rigorous training school which
emphasized both intellectual and
physical aspects of policing trainees
were educated in the latest
investigative procedures and
Technologies for example the use of an
enormous well-organized database of
fingerprints and other Innovation
imposed by Hoover later known as the
identification division it would
eventually offer access to the prince of
159 million people but rookie agents had
to also be men of action and were
trained in driving shooting an unarmed
combat Hoover's small army was now
poised to tackle what he had identified
as the greatest threat in the era of
prohibition Bootleggers boo Smugglers
and gangsters already romanticized by
Hollywood and popular culture it would
be natural to assume that the Boi would
go after Cosa Nostra and similar outfits
but throughout most of his career
director Hoover would dismiss this
organized crime initially he outright
denied the existence of the mafia later
he claimed that crime syndicates were a
matter for local rather than federal law
enforcement critics have obviously
speculated that Hoover may have been in
the pockets of a real-life Godfathers
the truth is that the director was a
frying strategist who wanted to bring
his organization to the spotlight and
build a long-lasting image of efficiency
to do this he cultivated a friendship
with reporter Courtney Riley Cooper the
author shared Hoover's love of Law and
Order and happily hopped him by writing
a series of Articles and books praising
the bureau but image was not all that
mattered Hoover also wanted tangible
immediate results what he wanted was for
his men's arrests to result in a 95
conviction rate could he achieve that by
taking on the mob no not a chance
organized crime was too much of a
formidable adversary and arresting her
mathioso would seldom result in a
conviction so the best way to score
early victories was to focus on
individual Bandits or small gangs
especially bank robbers operating in the
midwest one of the bureau's early
successes was the arrest of a robber and
prison escape e Frank Nash on June 16
1933. a team of four special agents and
three local policemen were escorting the
criminal to prison in Kansas City
Missouri uh when they were ambushed by
Nash's accomplices the attack lasted
only 30 seconds half a minute of
concentrated Tommy gunfire which killed
one agent and three police officers Nash
also died in the attack Hoover went on a
rampage ordering a Crackdown against the
most notorious criminals of the age
legendary gangsters feared and revered
by the public fell in Rapid succession
to the bullets of the G-men Ma Barker
Machine Gun Kelly John Dillon Ginger
Dillinger one of the most prolific bank
robbers of the age had been tracked down
and killed in Chicago on the 22nd of
July 1934 by special agent Mel Purvis
the G-Man became a national hero giving
to the bureau the coverage and ecstatic
headlines that the director craved but
on this occasion Hoover revealed his
narcissistic personality he hated the
fact that it was purpose not he who was
the man of the hour bathing in the
Limelight the director eventually had
his revenge Purvis was systematically
bullied and pressured on the job until
he had to resign from the bureau by July
of 1935 J Edgar Hoover was the
uncontested leader of America's most
efficient Federal agency fittingly the
once small Boi received a new name the
Federal Bureau of Investigation around
the same period President Roosevelt
expanded the brief of the FBI Beyond
regular criminal activities Hoover was
now called upon to investigate Japanese
German Italian and Soviet Espionage the
director took the opportunity to create
a vast network of domestic surveillance
on questionable individuals whose
alleged fascist or communist leadings
could posts a threat to National
Security these individuals were
cataloged in a custodial detention list
which would grow in the following
decades to include political activists
civil rights campaigners artists and
popular culture figures one of the first
VIPs to make the list thanks to a
liberal inclinations was the first lady
Eleanor Roosevelt for whom Hoover had a
personal dislike this was an early
instance of a recurring Hoover trademark
letting his personal antipathies dictate
his professional actions as the U.S
entered World War II the FBI ramped up
its efforts in domestic
counter-intelligence counter-espionage
and counter-sabotage investigations
Hoover was even asked to oversee a
foreign intelligence service in the
Western Hemisphere the special
intelligence service or sis during the
war the FBI initiated some twenty
thousand Espionage or sabotage
investigations against U.S or foreign
individuals suspected of supporting the
axis approximately a thousand of them
were detained Ellis Island The Immigrant
processing station in New York now let
me interrupt today's video for a short
word for today's sponsor Squarespace
look if you've ever wanted to start a
website but have been cut off by the
sort of complicated coding then
Squarespace is perfect for you building
an online presence it can be daunting
but no longer is an advanced coding
degree or a small fortune required in
order to get started Squarespace helps
you stand out with beautiful website
which you can easily build with their
drag and drop tools meaning anyone can
have the website of their dreams in no
time at all their platform provides you
with powerful analytics and insights
into visits your site and how they
interact with your content squarespace's
analytics tools include Pages traffic
sources audience geography and much more
that allows you to figure out what's
drawing your audience in and then
capitalize on that premium data that's
provided to you all as part of your
Squarespace subscription Squarespace
comes with powerful blogging tools as
well allowing you to share anything from
stories photos and videos to simple
updates for your fans or customers
connect your socials automatically you
can connect your socials and
automatically push website content to
your social media channels schedule your
posts and make your content work for you
the Squarespace members areas also allow
you to make it simple and easy to
monetize your content in a way that fits
with your brand unlock a new Revenue
stream for your business and sell
exclusive access to gated content for
your most dedicated customers you can
test out their platform before making
any commitments all you need to do is go
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
we're ready to launch your site go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now back to today's video
along the way Hoover was able to extend
his network of surveillance on U.S
citizens
the end of World War II marked the
beginning of Hoover's most intense
period of activity this coincided with
the onset of the Cold War on the
paranoia for Soviet infiltration
President Harry S Truman had signed
executive order 9835 initiating the
federal employees loyalty and security
program according to this program any
employees suspected of disloyalty or
communist sympathies could be
investigated by the FBI and dismissed
from their jobs the ebersealous Hoover
and his agents checked more than 14 000
Federal staff which resulted in 212
dismissed employees none of them were
involved in Espionage again this
activity gave the opportunity to Hoover
to further extend his surveillance on
citizens across all layers of society
Truman must have regretted giving him
such Powers as he later wrote We want no
gestapo or secret police FBI is tending
in that direction they are dabbling in
sex life scandals and plain blackmail
Edgar Hoover would give his right eye to
take over and all congressmen and
senators are afraid of Truman had Hit
Upon one of Hoover's obsessions sex the
bureau maintained files on politicians
activists civil servants and Hollywood
royalty alike documenting their alleged
or confirmed sexual indiscretions now
I'm not going to delve deeper into
Hoover's private life but I should point
out that the man himself was not immune
from potential scandals in 1947 he
elevated his long-term Protege Clyde
Tolson to the rank of associate director
but their interactions may have been
more than just professional the two were
inseparable inside and outside of the
office leading to speculation that they
were in a homosexual relationship and
that Hoover may have indulged in
cross-dressing but what was front and
center in Hoover's life at the time was
his commitment to anti-communism Hoover
cooperated with the house committee on
Un-American Activities which
investigated alleged Rebel activities of
citizens and organizations suspected of
having communist ties the FBI director
provided blacklists of suspected
individuals which he had been compiling
since the 1930s Hoover also supported
the crusade of Senator Joe McCarthy who
was convinced that both the Department
of State and the armed forces have been
infiltrated by the Communist party this
campaign frequently misfired and
Hoover's files led to many unfounded
allegations innocent individuals were
investigated or prosecuted simply
because of their tenuous association
with communist ideology or socialist
countries
a lesser-known anti-soviet plan of the
FBI director was Operation washed up
initially conceived by the Air Force's
office of special investigations or OSI
The OSI had realized that Alaska was
only a few miles away from Siberia what
if comrade Stalin and a few mates from
the Red Army invaded there how about
creating a resistance movement of
sleeper agents prior to the invasion FBI
special agent John Williams in Anchorage
Alaska was not impressed with the plan
but in June of 1950 Hoover overruled him
Williams was ordered to start building
an Alaskan stay behind Network and so it
was that the FBI and OSI recruited and
trained 100 cells of five to seven
operatives with orders to initiate
Guerrilla actions after a potential Red
Army invasion they had access to caches
of goodies which included explosive
Firearms garage and loads of canned food
because apparently you can't set fire to
a Soviet tank on an empty stomach a
recruit had to be middle-aged civilians
preferably with extreme survival skills
a memo from The OSI to the FBI describes
the ideal washed up recruit in Anchorage
here's an amateur radio operator he is
licensed as a hunting and fishing guide
and a well-versed in the art of survival
here's a pilot of small aircraft and
possessed of sufficient physical courage
as is indicated by his offer to guide a
party which was to have hunted Kodiak
bear armed with only Beau and arrow
Downs Mike a bit of a badass but
wouldn't the Soviets immediately round
up a guy like that well that would have
actually been unlikely as the memo
clarifies he has only one arm and it is
felt that he would not benefit the enemy
in any labor Battalion well that settles
it the Soviet invasion of course never
materialized however the maintenance
costs did the FBI and OSI racked up an
annual bill of at least 21 million
dollars in today's money until they
terminated operation washed up in 1959.
based on this account it sounds as
though Hoover and his men had been
completely blinded by paranoia leading
to unfruitful and costly efforts to
fight a non-existing enemy but that
would be unfair as the concern about
communist Espionage was justified this
was confirmed by one of Hoover's most
resounding successes the arrest of a
network of confirmed Soviet moles
stealing secrets on the American nuclear
warfare program ringleaders Julius and
Ethel Rosenberg were executed on June 19
1953.
in 1956 director Hoover launched a
program that would forever mark his
legacy the counter-intelligence program
or cointel Pro this was a covert
operation exposed only in March of 1971
when the self-appointed citizens
commission to investigate the FBI broke
into an FBI office in Media Pennsylvania
and stole confidential files the
break-in revealed the extent of cointel
pro the FBI used extra legal means to
discredit harass undermine and dismantle
organizations considered subversive to
U.S political stability Hoover's targets
include a political organizations like
the Communist Party USA the Puerto Rican
nationalist party in the American Indian
movement a great deal of attention was
also reserved for civil rights movements
such as the Black Panther Party and
Martin Luther King's Southern Christian
leadership conference and
segregationists were not immune either
as the Ku Klux Klan was in the FBI sites
too cointelpro was rather Limited in
scope accounting for 0.2 percent of the
FBI's workload over a 15-year period
most projects involved agents writing
Anonymous letters to create enmity
amongst two actions so in language we
used today they were essentially
creating false accounts just to troll
people an example of this is Operation
Hoodwink which was active from the fall
of 1966 to July 1968. FBI agents under
Alias wrote to left-wing Publications
criticizing the practice of loan
sharking or other activities associated
with the Italian mafia the plan was to
set Costa Nostra and other syndicates
against the Communist Party the New York
office of the bureau eventually
convinced Hoover to abandon the
operation as Hoodwink had not generated
any tangible result a similar approach
did have some violent consequences when
applied to the Black Panther's party the
295 documented actions taken by
cointelpro to disrupt African-American
activism 233 were directed against the
Black Panther Party its co-founder Huey
P Newton argued in his doctoral thesis
that Hoover used false letters and
documents to create Discord between the
Black Panthers and other groups such as
the United slaves according to Newton
this Rift may have escalated into the
murders of black panther members our
Apprentice Bunchy Carter and John
Huggins who were shot down at the
University of California on the 17th of
January 1969. later that year the FBI
struck again against the Panthers
according to a 1976 Senate report
intelligence applied to the Chicago
Police led to the 4th of December raid
against Fred Hampton a local leader of
the Panthers the FBI performance may
have caused the police to intervene with
unjustified disproportionate Force
officers fired 98 rounds which killed
Hampton and his associate Mark Clark and
wounded four others a separate
Commission of inquiry concluded that
there is cause to believe that Fred
Hampton was shot by officers while lying
on his bed before turning his attention
to the Black Panther Party Hoover
developed an obsession with another
civil rights activist Martin Luther King
Jr who was suspected of communist
affiliations in January 1962 Hoover had
learned that some of King's speeches
have been written by Stanley Levinson a
former financier for the Communist Party
the director promptly informed Attorney
General Robert Kennedy the two men
despised each other but Kennedy
authorized the bugging of levison's
Office later in the year Dr King
publicly criticized the FBI's
investigation of racially motivated
crimes this is when Hoover's suspicion
of King as a communist sympathizer
developed into a personal dislike and
eventually an obsession Hoover convinced
Bob Kennedy to extend surveillance on an
associate of levison and Kings Clarence
B Jones in August of 1963 King stayed at
Jones's place and Hoover's wiretaps
recorded something unexpected proof of
Reverend King's extramarital Affairs in
October Bob Kennedy yielded to Hoover's
precious and authorized direct
surveillance on King the FBI head
assigned the investigation to assistant
director Sullivan who focused on
documenting the activist's sex life on
tape Sullivan went as far as
blackmailing King with an anonymous
letter the message included a veiled
invite for the minister to commit
suicide King ignored the threat and the
FBI didn't go public with the Scandal
but Hoover and King continued a feud
throughout night 64. King accused Hoover
of siding with segregationists while
Hoover replied by calling him the most
notorious liar in the country and a
sexual degenerate Hoover lifted some of
the pressure on King in 1965 for simple
admin when the Kings moved to a new
house the FBI director did not authorize
the bugging of the new place apparently
I wanted to cut down on the number of
wiretaps but in February and April of
1967 Dr King denounced the war in
Vietnam this alienated the Johnson
administration's support and spurred
Hoover to attack again his co-indel Pro
agents orchestrated a press campaign to
discredit the Reverend and sabotage
King's fundraising efforts his civil
rights organization the SCRC was forced
to lay off much of its staff less than
one year later on the 4th of April 1968
Martin Luther King Jr was assassinated
in Memphis Hoover decreed the
investigation on the shooting as a top
priority thanks to the FBI's extensive
fingerprint database the murderer was
identified as James Earl Ray arrested on
the 8th of June after an international
Manhunt so a victory for justice with
Hoover at the helm while not according
to Rey's attorney William F Pappa his
theory is the doctor King's
assassination was part of a large
conspiracy masterminded by Hoover and
his Deputy Clyde Tolson but look out for
her episodes on Martin Luther King and
James Earl Ray for more details on
between the FBI and the Civil Rights
Movement based on what we've discussed
so far one may argue that Hoover was a
supporter of segregation but don't
forget that another one of his key
targets was the KKK a branch of cointel
pro named white hate was launched in
September 1964 to strike at the KKK whom
Hoover denounced as cowardly jackals to
this end the FBI disseminated
Intelligence on KKK activities to
journalists and politicians driving
public opinion against the clan in a
contorted yet effective move Hoover fed
the notion that the KKK rallies
negatively affected investment Decisions
by military contractors thus hindering
America's war effort in Vietnam
conclusion the clan was an anti-American
organization unwittingly favoring the
Communist cause special agents also
employed informants and insiders to
circulate discrediting information about
the clan leaders among members
inculcating disillusionment and driving
resignations from local chapters
evidence of embezzlement was very useful
of course but even more useful was that
old Hoover Chestnut of sexual immoral
an example of this tactic oh was the
campaign against J Robert Jones The
Grand Dragon for North Carolina the FBI
distributed cartoons depicting Jones as
he squandered Clan funds on extramarital
Affairs the cartoonist must have been
very talented as the plan led to
infighting and resignations in North
Carolina eventually white hate did play
a part in shifting perception of the KKK
in the South its violence against black
activists or ordinary citizens had been
widely tolerated up to the early 1960s
then by the late 1960s the Press public
opinion and finally also jury's
perceived klansmen as anti-American
extremists
up until the citizens break-in of 1971
Hoover and his FBI enjoyed a positive
reputation with the general public the
director was hailed as the nation's
Defender who led a modern detective
Force taking down Public Enemies with
the help of scientific work and field
action but Hoover's enemies and some of
his employers knew they better steer
clear of him and his unorthodox extra
legal approach that is why when the 77
year old died in his sleep on May the
2nd 1972 he left behind a controversial
Legacy the very same day President Nixon
lamented his loss at a press conference
every American in my opinion owes J
Edgar Hoover a great debt for building
the FBI into the finest law enforcement
organization in the entire world but in
private he expressed relief that the old
sucker is
depending on your stance J Edgar Hoover
may be remembered as America's top cop
or is its Sinister Chief Inquisitor his
achievements as head of the bureau 48
uninterrupted years are undeniable so is
the fact that 48 years of such
tremendous power concentrated into a
single individual could easily become a
recipe for abuse
[Music]